[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
what does everyone have a sage
that's why i don't wear sunglasses
big story north korea is celebrating the
one year anniversary of kim jong-un's
ascension to power
yeah
that's right that's right one year ago
today kim jong-un ascended to power by
climbing onto a phone book
true story that was the ceremony and he
got one
now they're up to something uh today
true story north korea raised a missile
to an upright position then later tucked
it back into its launcher
that's true
north korea did all this after its wife
went to bed
it just sounds creepy
who's watching the masters anybody
watching the masters all right
thank you sir
this year one guy yes
this year a 14 year old boy from china
is the youngest golfer to ever compete
in the masters
yeah
youngest
yeah he's doing well
yeah during his round of golf today the
chinese boy made two birdies an eagle
and an ipad
why am i doing this
i'm making a stone age ipad you have a
basic misunderstanding of high
technology no i'm not good at that stuff
nasa has big plans nasa has announced a
plan to lasso an asteroid and bring it
closer to earth
this is according to the head of nasa a
six-year-old boy
they really want to do that that's a
real plan they have why bring it closer
i don't know
i don't know
i i have no idea we just tell jokes we
don't tell the news yeah yeah we don't
read the whole paper
we just read the part that can help us
with the jokes
on tuesday at the white house president
obama sang with justin timberlake
yeah
it's being called the blackest thing
president obama has ever done
[Applause]
dc we have any comic fans here dc comics
[Music]
dc comics has introduced its first ever
transgender character
yeah
the character is called wonder if it's a
woman
[Applause]
turn around again
i don't know
i don't know crazy story in maine a
hermit living in the woods was arrested
he claims he's only seen one human since
1986.
now i think he's telling the truth
because for his one phone call he tried
to reach mr belvedere
you saved it sir thank you
do you even know who mr belvedere is
no you have no idea dude
i i think i know why he's wearing
sunglasses i know
this is really happening man
[Laughter]
listen to this one gang
stephen hawking
you know the scientist and the brilliant
man
stephen hawking said that unless we find
a way to escape earth human beings will
not survive this current millennium
yeah
yeah hawking made the prediction at what
turned out to be an incredibly
depressing baby shower
[Music]
totally
total buzz kill for everybody
except this guy
here in hollywood an actress is suing a
website for revealing her actual age
however the lawsuit will be dropped if
tmz apologizes to 33-year-old betty
white
we're waiting to find out we'll let you
know